- C'est devenu presque banal
de les voir dans les villages
côtoyer la vie normale.
Des soldats à l'épie,e,e, des
chars et des obusiers à la gare.
Des jeunes hommes en uniforme
qui, eux seuls, connaissent
leurs ordres ou attettt
de les recevoir.
Nous sommes à Pokrovskoïe,
à 50 km de la frontière, et
le chemin de fne tout droit
vers les territoires de Donetsk
et de Louhansk. Pendant que
le soleil se couchait ici,
à Mosa a a a Douma franchissait
un pas de plus vers le scénario
de guerre...
... en donnant officiellement
au président Vladimir Poutine
le feu vert officiel pour qu'il
envoie l'armée dans ces enclaves
de l'Ukraine.
Mais dans les faits, les troupes
russes sont déjà arrivées,
et la population célèbre.
SVETLANA KISSILEVA,
résidente de Donetsk, Ukraine
- Bien, nous, on est contents.
Pour nous, c'est la protection.
- Il faut se rabattre sur
les vidéos et les témoignages
de résidents que nous
connaissons à Donetsk, comme
Sletvana, pour savuiuiuiuiui
se passe depuis 24 heures.
Qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
pour les prochains jours?
- Bien, que l'Ukraine nous
lanqnqnqnqnquilles. C'est
ce qu'on a toujours demandé.
- C'est-à-dire, l'autonomie,
une fois pour toutes.
Mais jusqu'où exactement au-delà
a a a a a ligne de front?
Et à quel prix?
Alors, Monsieur Poutine a
décidé de reconnaître
l'autonomie de ces deux
territoires ukrainiens. Es
qu'elle reconnaît sur leur forme
actuelle ou est-ce qu'elle
reconnaît sous leur forme
historique, c'est-à-dire pour
comprendre des vilntntntntntnt
sous contrôle ukrainien en ce
moment, comme Marioupol.Dans unu
et provocateur, Vladimir Poutine
a confirmé ce soir qu'il
Reconnaît l'ensemble de la
région.
Poutine se dit même prêt
à délimilitariser l'Ukraine
pour protéger son pays.
s s s s s s s villes limitrophes
comme Pokrovskoïe, où l'armée
russe se prépare, les résidents
s'inquiètent de la catastrophe
en devenir chez leur voisin.
"C'est la faute des Américains.
Ce sont eux qui poussent les
Ukrainiens vers nos frontières",
dit Olga.
Sa voisine, Maria, dit qu'elle
est terrifiée et croit que
Poutine a tort de défendre
des soi-disant Russes de l'autre
côté de la frontière.
"C'est nous, le peuple, qui
allons souffrir des sanctions.
Pas le président Poutine
et les proches du pouvoir."
Maria dit qu'elle s'était
réjouie, comme beaucoup d'autres
Russes, de l'annexion
de la Crimée en 2014.
"Mais le Donbass, en Ukraine,
dit-elle, il n'en vaut pas
la peine."
La vérité est que si Vladimir
Po        à reprendre
la Crimée, sans tirer un seul
coup de feu en 2014, le sort
de l'Ukraine en 2022 pourrait
être tristement différent.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada,
à Pokrovskoïe, en Russie